big news in the fight against the
coronavirus starting today
everybody in nevada 16 and older can get
the vaccine
yeah this is seen as a critical step in
the local fight against coven 19. we
have hector mejia
live from the las vegas convention
center vaccination site with the details
hey hector
hey there good morning and with the
eligibility expanding health officials
hope it speeds up our recovery and we
are expecting to see lines at
vaccination sites
across the valley including here at the
las vegas convention center
and so far more than 26 percent of
nevada's population has gotten at least
their first dose of the coronavirus
vaccine
that's according to state numbers this
morning the cdc recently updated travel
guidelines saying
fully vaccinated people can now travel
domestically
adding another incentive to get the
vaccine now that everyone 16 and up is
eligible the goal is for the state's
positivity rate to drop some more
it's currently holding at 4.2 percent i
think it's going to be great because
we have to control this pandemic but as
soon as i can i just gotta go get it and
get it
i'm terrified needle so i won't be
getting until i need to but if it comes
down to i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
fight if it's a requirement
the cdc says covet vaccines are
effective at protecting you from getting
sick
the state updated its website saturday
afternoon two days ahead of eligibility
if you are looking to schedule an
appointment we have step-by-step
instructions on our website
eightnewsnow.com just click on the story
and you can also
make an appointment through the southern
nevada health district's website we have
a link to that page
on our website as well reporting live
this morning hector mejia
eight news and